yeah welcome to this video a 15-minute
game again here all I see see a play you
for getting some variety and French
defense okay let's play d4 quickly and
um decide now what to play all right
let's go for the terror that's a wide
choice obviously 93 nowadays as some
probably considered more critical but
it's all metal of choice and meta matter
of taste and the matter of taste I
wanted to say okay yeah here White has
some three principled setups Bishop d3
and 9 to e 2 nite g to e 2 and then my D
to f3 Bishop d3 and Nagi two or three
which is sometimes called the universal
system because it can be applied against
some other moves orders as well or you
can go F for which is the most ambitious
now I play and form the idea is to play
Knight d2 f3 later and build up this
this big center with the F form and um
this leaf I've bridgehead so I just got
pretty big space advantage in the center
typical of the French with F for this is
some consolidated the space advantage to
nob like can can play em a multitude of
moves in these closed positions them you
often got a bit of a bit of a choice
complain Queen B 6 now or Bishop to e7 a
very solid option is to go for f5 now on
after the exchange on d4 just blocking
the position completely years ago when I
was still playing the French as black
gown I'm um build up a set up with h5
took on d4 Knight b6 and then g6 h5 very
yeah solid but also passive setup didn't
have much success with this this applies
to my results with the French in general
but um ok now let's see what what is
what is going for Queen B 6 is the most
interesting actually trying to put up
put pressure against this d4 pawn yeah
and now why it has some choice again you
can play the traditional move g3 which
consolidates the center bit more evening
after taking we should be for check you
go King f2 after which black can team
play a g5 pretty wild line right can
play h for this is directed against g5
or you can play a 3 which I'm going to
do now a 3 is directed against this
Bishop before check move okay not not
nothin to want to think about what needs
to recapture okay so how should them
should I proceed now I would like to
play Bishop to d3 of course this is the
natural square the Danny um yeah he can
take on d for something he hasn't
canceled yet and does not this Bishop b5
check a trick it's not turn on okay I
could play Knight e 2 e 2 233 maybe why
can't I could play something like h4h
form night h3 and we should be to
something like this yeah quite a wide
choice okay
good beef oh this is also possible
before to prepare Bishop e3 the only
problem is that it further delays my
development but ok let's sound the most
ambitious move also it done gains the
space on the queenside so that you
cannot go night to a five for example if
we can see for though it must be careful
black could easily play the Queen back
to da door c7 and try to play Knight b6
to see for at some point not that it is
fatal if neither sonsie for but then
it's a square the Attic black should
probably consider on f6 or castles and
f6 trying to open up the position it's
often very funny in this line says that
divides it's moving his pants all the
time and he hasn't even canceled yet so
we must be careful this can this can be
on this can end in absolutely great
position for white where you completely
dominate the board because you've got
this this huge space advantage but it
can also really have hit your heart if
you if you get stuck in the center with
the king and black opens up we have with
f6 quickly okay so if I would if I if I
would know I shouldn't say that right if
i play m22 now I would cover III is
threatening to take on e5 actually to
take on e5 and then take with the night
because my III Bishop is some thats
hanging
so one Queen d2 would be in it is a
natural move to cover the e3 bishop I
need to check night eggs before matrix
before a bee Bishop before would win the
Queen so okay should I am I could also
play a bishop to f2 but after canceled
some does this taking only five idea
again and not really maybe Bishop f2 it
looks terribly slow and light takes
before it's an option may be still and
don't have don't have a good development
this is so okay what about a queen d
three maybe but I came I'd literally
like I would really like to have a
bishop on on d3 flipper sure that's just
it must be only three this is this the
square for this piece so Bishop f2 after
all but night before is really annoying
or not before I have rope you on maybe
not sure that is it out like that though
alright if he takes on before I need to
somehow I need to defend this it's um
it's probably not to correct any way for
black but it simply looks them looks a
bit with we had an ITEX before what's an
option problem okay so let's set up the
way I really want to have the pieces
Bishop d3 and 92 which is the ideal
ideal setup it all works nicely together
with supporting the center and down the
bishop is simply perfectly placed on d3
eyeing the h7 porn and the King side but
also exerting influence on the queenside
so the best square sometimes in these
positions there's g3 Bishop h3 it's also
an option but if you have the possible
if they've got the chance to put it on
d3 then this is the way to go yeah I'm
not quite sure um how black should
proceed here you need to do something
concrete I mean if you if you just play
passive moves let's say rook somewhere
on left look I know F 7 and 9 f8 or
something you're simply worse with the
space disadvantage um all this kind of
stuff not sure what this is doing ok
let's complete development damn don't
really understand the purpose of King
edge aid what black is always able to do
he can always play am still on play f5
and close the position this is a
possibility in the long run wyd would
prepare yeah g4 against that end should
enjoy some advantage should simply but
more space and you are the one to UM
care to dictate the opening of the plane
you play g4 and like not sure if it can
can take of course I'm not talking about
f5 g4 immediately but after some
preparation you have the the one you are
the one playing g4 and then you decide
if you take at some point or play g5 h4
h5 and so on you're the one with the
space advantage so um this is more
comfortable for white f5 but it's fairly
solid
a one idea but it takes some really a
long time would be to play something
like the bishop on CA to the some
typical a bad French bishop try to get
this piece to be five getting it
exchanged it takes a long time though
need to move both nights and then go
ahead with the bishop this is one idea
our black could do is finally move this
Queen from b6 which is really not on not
particularly well placed at the moment
move this to move this Queen and play
Knight b6 maybe this is an idea of
something like I'm Queen to d8 Knight b6
knight c6 287 Bishop d7 to a b5 it takes
ages but it's a it's a plan constructive
plan no it doesn't turn doesn't move
gasps something like this maybe you need
to untie this these pieces on d7c 6 p-6
NC 8 there are some players standing on
each other's toes those pieces what did
you play our queen c7 yeah this was was
a like the idea I mentioned not sure
that this c7 is so great though and
maybe he wants to go be 5v5 and 8th I
have something like this or b-five not
be 64 also I'm also a possibility okay
should i should i cancel I mean this is
not not clear if I really am still
should cancel is it a good idea to play
em to play Queen Queen see to Patek the
age seven points so that blankets
provoked to player f5 I also wonder
maybe 22 and then looks you want to
prevent even be five now that looks um
it's very passive on this this position
for black
or maybe rook c1 and on b5 I have Quincy
to em with a double attack yeah this
looks this looks nice the rook is not
bad on c1 anyway opposing the the black
queen and I have my kid mind my options
open him one idea i also spotted as sh
form h4 with the idea to play 95 as a
piece sacrifice i don't know let's say h
495 I would move two in a row this looks
really dangerous h takes g5 h tags ft x
g5 HTG fun open up the H file and how
does the cover h7 even let don't think
it can and after H 4935 there's a6
hanging and age 17 so can't even play f5
so H foursome is an option I wasn't sure
if he M replies f5 um if I have
something good then I mean in there in a
position with f5 I don't really want to
play h form I want to play for g4 and
keep the phone on age 32 support g-form
so h 4f 54 smile I'm a problem my
objection to to this IDM let's it's
still interesting platform aha now this
is surprising opening up the King side
is really questionable d takes d5 also
was fine with 94 coming I ctrl v4
perfectly but I wanted to
to have f4 for the night so something
like 22 nite f4 age 49 f 495 and so on
yeah this looks very very dangerous not
for back he doesn't really gain anything
substantial from the capture only five
sometimes you can open up the FR to to
to sacrifice an exchange on a 3-yard
even play p sacrifice on five in those
kind of lines but not anymore with all
the time lost
yeah the question is some is this age
495 idea of an option now he cannot down
play a five anymore and the tacking h7s
is dangerous yeah certainly certainly an
option another idea would be a bishop to
be one and 23 lining up the standard
battery on age seven young it's a
multitude of a good options yeah maybe
you should try to kill Luke f7 idea
being night f8 and covering at age seven
Brooke or look somewhere else d 8 it
looks weird to leave the FR idea what
rook da twas roop the 8 9 f8 Bishop d7
EA g6 this would be a Senate maneuver
but it takes so long I mean you're
probably made already before you even
have to Bishop halfway on the King side
this is again just going to be a real
quick this can be real quick now uh-huh
back to d8
hmm yeah h 495 it serve as an option all
this some on this maneuver with bishop
be 123 i also like that yeah come on
it's not waste too much time he's down
to two minutes something and he's not
speeding up okay I didn't take that into
account at all it's not them
particularly great probably but I really
didn't them didn't consider it I what I
could do is just play a queen d3
threatening mate and then then react to
this like Bishop e3 are taking and
Bishop e3 okay this was one this was my
idea anyway so let's threaten this mate
and here you cannot cover it with a
piece like night fhe must play g6 now
there's no other move and after this g6
maybe i can i can just take on g5 and
play castles with the intention of
Bishop e3 to h6 yeah this looks looks
disastrous really there any way to to
defend this probably I have even other
options but this is this is good enough
and castles nom he's got all pants on
light squares so the dark squares are a
terribly weak and um
I have this Bishop b3 thing coming yeah
okay let's or is there something better
let's check you should age for now
probably not but this is this is
perfectly fine i want i want to go to h6
or g5 he needs to give me the F file
also know that Phaedra was hanging so
you should 86 thread new look f8 with
really close to a checkmate on NYE
deform just taking on g6 now their form
this is very direct to see does he have
anything again this even get this
capture and neither form he probably
yeah Queen g7 on other moves I just take
it on g6
and yeah come on this looks looks good
enough to win g7 is the only move now to
avoid the immediate winning sacrifice on
g6 but don't go in g 7i have various
moves one interesting try being a knight
h5 taking Bishop g5 with the idea Bishop
f6 oh no I can even quicker on Queen g7
I could play night h5 takes and rook f8
with mate yeah okay and now I can just I
can just take he's got no way to prevent
Queen age 6 down okay can do this but it
shouldn't really help and that Bishop h6
something better and I don't think so
let's check this just for a second yeah
we should be aight briefly irritated me
but i can just go play Queen edge form
yeah the queen is a text now and if he
m-maybe goes Queen somewhere please I
don't know Queen g5s winning or rogue f8
um so on got more than one win now but
other this is this is this is cute just
change queens and this checkmate yeah
this line is is dangerous for black head
sir it can easily lead to these kind of
one sided games if you don't really know
what your you're doing concretely um I'm
not one hundred percent sure one
possible idea for bloggers for example a
five here to prevent before or just do
f5 or clay like in the game with f6 but
just just quicker avoiding a six and
another moves in the in the game it was
just very good for white this kind of
position is just better for white I was
irritated by this light takes before
idea I want to check it quickly Knight
takes before just because i was i was
thinking that the King e2 is a very
uncomfortable move but this is still our
idea yeah I thought so because I now
have free to f3 from my from the other
night so i can i can cover all this so
this wasn't i wasn't a problem the
computer actually wants to play g5 and
gives a black on pretty good assessment
here g5 is interesting
attacking the center yeah black needs to
play actively if you feed the some
places too many passive moves like in
the game you simply get get get
destroyed this is this is indeed
interesting let's say I would take here
then the computer wants to play Knight
f6 yeah this is indeed interesting night
g5 and now or something like this yeah
this is just a complete mess but it
certainly takes white out of his comfort
zone yeah the position is opened and
yeah your king us on only one it's not
not so easy to play this and not saying
this is better for black or something
but you need to play some active stuff
to to get counter play in the game it
was after after I got to cut this
completed it's very one-sided you can
play something like f 5 22 yeah sort of
yeah batten down the hatches and try to
try to survive all this but yeah I think
this this is now really close to close
to win it's very hard to very hard to
defend the King cytotec this is just one
one one option
yeah he also Bishop Bishop h6 was was
good but not air force was strong I was
thinking just move but I can I can just
play here with the idea that this is
checkmate and after not age 54 what
should you do this is this stuff gets
gets really ugly for example yeah and a
sad end to this game yeah thanks for
watching I think was a pretty good
example that in the French defense where
why it takes much space you need to play
active defense if you play passively it
can be very one-sided yeah thanks for
watching